she was an exotic dancer in Paris at the
height of the Belle époque she was the
object of sexual desire for wealthy men
ambassadors and high-ranking officers
she was matter Harry the dancer the spy
one of the great names of World War one
espionage novels movies even video games
and a young Indiana Jones episode have
channeled a character that is now the
stuff of legends a shrewd manipulative
and fatale spying and double-crossing on
both Germany and the Allies at the
height of World War one motivated only
by greed and the need to maintain an
extravagant lifestyle she was margarita
von Zell also known as matter Harry also
known as agent h20 one of the German
secret service she was accused of
causing the death of 50,000 French
soldiers and met her deserved fate in
front of a firing squad on a cold
October morning in 1917 but before you
pronounce your verdict stop and think in
a world of spies nothing is as it seems
the commonly accepted narrative of
matter Harry may indeed just be a
fabrication was she really the ruthless
double agents the French counter
espionage wanted you to believe or wish
she simply a pawn on the European chess
board lost in a game that she could
barely understand documents recently
Declassified by the French Secret
Service's reveal a whole new truth which
well we're about to tell Mata Hari was
born margarita Gertrude as Elle on the
7th of August 1876 she was born in the
town of Louisville to a relatively
well-off family her first years of life
they were largely uneventful until the
day when aged 13 her beloved father Adam
abandoned her and her mother to live
with another woman two years later her
mother and she had died with no other
sustenance margarita was sent away by
relatives to study to become a teacher
margarita was now 15 and had bloomed
with a dark intention and exotic looks
she stood out like an orchid among
dandelo
that was according to a schoolmate this
friend was not the only one to notice
age 16 margarita was expelled from
school for having an affair with the
headmaster two years later she was
living in the hague bought miserable and
yearning for an adventure away from the
netherlands she found a way out through
a lonely heart sattva posted by a dutch
colonial officer of scottish descent
captain rudolf macleod who was 22 years
a senior they married in july of 1895
if margarita wanted adventure in life
McCloud would offer it he was posted to
the Dutch colonies in Indonesia and
things well they didn't really get much
more exotic than that their married life
in Indonesia though it was not a happy
one MacLeod was a serious adulterer and
physically abusive she resorted to
having numerous affairs with young
officers posted in the colony but the
worst thing was that Rudolf had
contracted syphilis by one of his
mistresses infecting Margaret's errands
by hereditary transmission their two
children
Norman John and Louise gene who had been
born in 1896 and 1898 Norman's case it
was severe and he received the only
available treatment at the time and his
mercury the local doctor overdosed the
child who sadly died from mercury
poisoning aged only two this was the
final blow for the McClouds marriage
they separated and after returning to
the Netherlands in 1902 they formally
got divorced a divorced woman like
margarita in the early 20th century
would have been at a tremendous
disadvantage but she did not surrender
in our colonial days she had picked up
more than just an STD from that
gentleman MacLeod she could also speak
fluent German French Italian Spanish and
Malay most of all she could dance she
had learned some local Malay and
Indonesian dances unknown to European
audiences of the early 1900's and this
is where her career truly started
imagine the setting it's Paris during
the Belle Epoque a period that lasted
from 1871 to 1914 in which French
economy culture and the arts were
flourishing the scene the game a Museum
of Asian art enter an unknown dancer who
is going to stun high society of Paris
with her bold moves inspired by the
mysterious rituals of the Far East her
name used to be margarita MacLeod
but now it's just matter Harry the eye
of the dawn in the Millea language it
was the start of a stellar career that
would take her from private parties to
the most celebrated theatres in Europe
in fact matter Harry's shows would have
been completely banned in any other
context even by the loose standards of
the Belle Epoque she would perform with
a loose and transparent robes very often
stripping almost completely naked and
yet she always got away by stating that
she was simply re-enacting the sacred
dances of the priestesses of some cult
or another that was in Indonesia during
the following year her celebrity grew
not only because of her performances but
mainly because of the affairs and the
gossip that surrounded her her patrons
included journalists lawyers
government's officials army officers the
top echelon of Paris society and they
repaid her favors in lavish gifts
clothes jewels or just plain cash now
it's time that we dispel a myth that's
always surrounded matter Harry the fact
that she was little more than a
prostitute and had an appetite for sex
with powerful men in a series of letters
to her cousin Edward published in 2017
matter Harry confesses how she had
developed a loathing for sex after her
unfortunate relationship with MacLeod if
sometimes she consented to a
relationship with a powerful friend it
was only so that she could provide for
her beloved daughter Louise it was a
fact nonetheless that her dancing had
made her famous but it was how wealthy
acquaintances that had made her rich
these acquaintances became ever more
important with time as the Belle époque
gradually slid into the warning signs of
the water Wendell Wars demands for her
shows it started to wane in June of 1914
she had received an offer to dance in
Berlin it was too good an opportunity to
miss unfortunately the show was
cancelled due to a small mishap
Germany's declaration of war against
Russia on the 1st of August this meant
it was time for Mata Hari to go back to
Paris alas there were other small thing
prevented her from doing so and that was
Germany's declaration of war against
France on the 3rd of August yep World
War one
it had begun Matt Harry decided then to
return to a real home for Hague she
could have settled there and enjoyed a
quiet life in one of the few remaining
neutral powers of Europe she could have
done that but she didn't it
in the autumn of 1915 the matter Harry
started dating one Karl Cromer
apparently the honorary consul of
Germany in Amsterdam but actually an
agent for the Kaiser Secret Service
chroma had a plan he would recruit this
beautiful woman who carried a neutral
passport and spoke several languages to
seduce top brass in the allied field and
report back any secrets she could gather
her reward 20,000 francs this is when
accounts start to differ according to
the official inquiry that would follow
this is when Mata Hari officially became
agent h21 and started her campaign to
harm the Allied war effort for the sole
reason of earning more and more cash to
fund a lavish lifestyle
feel free to believe the legends but the
declassified documents they suggest a
rather different story matter Harry
declines the offer but she kept the
twenty thousand francs in her eyes this
was rightful compensation for having her
furs and jewels seized by German border
guards at the outbreak of the war having
regained some funds and some confidence
matter Harry returned to her spiritual
home of Paris sailing to France from the
Netherlands in December of that year her
ship was docked in the English port of
Folkston and all passengers there were
questions by a British intelligence
officer the officer noted a matter Harry
she speaks French English Italian Dutch
and probably German handsome bold type
of woman well and fashionably dressed
and the final verdict not above
suspicion and she should be refused
permission to return to the UK this
overzealous officer even sent a message
about Matt Harry to the French Newseum
Bureau or second office which was the
counter espionage unit of the Ministry
of War headed by captain George LeDoux
it was January of 1916 now matter Harry
was back in Paris and had resumed her
old habits hanging out with dashing
officers and powerful under secretaries
but something had changed she was being
followed LeDoux's agents they shadowed
her every move opens her mail and
intercepted of phone calls I'm gonna
present again both versions of this
story ladies and gentlemen of the jury
according to the official inquiry the
counterespionage unit was gathering
intelligence on matter Harry spying for
the Germans but the facts are that the
evidence they collected amounted to
nothing
[Music]
that's Enya Mata Hari met Vladimir damn
a Slav probably her first love and
certainly the greatest of her life Tomas
Olaf was a decorated Russian captain who
had been partially blinded in one eye
while fighting on the Western Front when
Vladimir proposed matahari
accepted happily but he had to leave for
the front again and how could she stay
close to him
despite her passport from a neutral
country matter Harry needed a special
safe-conduct to travel near the front
lines and this is where Zsa Haller an
ex-lover enters the picture Jean
apparently worked for the war
departments but unofficially he was
reporting to captain LeDoux Shaw
arranged for an appointment form at a
hurry to meet the doozy M Bureau and the
captain placed his offer on the table
the exotic dancer would become a spy for
them seducing high-ranking German
targets in neutral countries to capture
military secrets in exchange captain
LeDoux would give her the safe contact
she needed and also a million francs by
the way that's more than three million
American dollars in today's money this
would have been more than enough to
support mass loss and herself after they
married especially if he did not recover
his sight or his aristocratic family
disowned him let who instructed matter
Harry to wait for instructions before
going back to the hague via Spain these
were instructions though that never came
she did not know what intelligence she
was meant to gather whom to targets nor
how to communicate in secret
tired of waiting she eventually wrote
him by regular post asking at least for
an advance if she was going to seduce an
important man she needed to buy some new
clothes
finally on Rufus Pen matter Harry's ship
was yet again stopped at a British port
and she was questioned once more this
time the British transferred her to
London and kept her under custody until
November of 1916 that's what was going
on well it seems that the British secret
service mi5 were trying to establish if
she was indeed Margarita's Elle aka
matter Harry or one Clara Benedict's and
actual German secret agents this was a
sticky situation which matter Harry
tried to resolve by admitting to being a
French agent the British contacted
LeDoux and his reply was understand
nothing
send matter Harry back to Spain so was
his game well according to the author
Pat shipment mi Phi's interpretation was
that LeDoux suspected her for sometime
of being a German agent and had only
pretended to employ her he would have
been only too happy to have the Brits
get rid of her
but also on this occasion they let her
go in December of 1916 matter Harry set
to work in Madrid without instructions
but determined to win her reward she
seduced a German diplomat major arnold
von cow
they spent only three afternoons in bed
but it was enough he let it slip that
the German Navy with their Ottoman
allies were planning his submarine
landing in Morocco which was then a
French colony the Germans found to open
a new front in North Africa well this
was huge news matter Harry sent a
message to LeDoux to inform him and his
response so why did Allah do not respond
to her did he not trust her or the
intelligence that she'd captured well
mazza Harry she sought advice from
another lover this time a French officer
Colonel Joseph Don Vania dovey Nia asked
her to extract more information about
the Moroccan landing from Karl which she
did was a bad move Carla the Germans now
became suspicious and decided to act
American journalist trust more on how in
1985 claimed to have access to the
matter Harry dossier which had been kept
secret by the doozy M Bureau since 1917
according to him well the German secret
service did was incredibly sneaky
suspecting that matter Harry was a
French spy and still resentful that she
had extorted 20,000 francs from Kramer
in 1915 Karl and his cronies sent a
secret radio message to Berlin to get
rid of her this message implicated the
matter Harry was actually a german
double agent but the evil genius part
was that they used a code which they
knew the French had already cracked
the message was intercepted by a
listening post located on top of the
Eiffel Tower I mean it is a big aerial
after all and this was promptly relayed
to LeDoux who now had the evidence that
he needed to arrest matter Harry so the
German agents they'd manipulated to do
into doing their own dirty work
but LeDoux was only too happy to have
been manipulated
he had suspected her from the start and
the French public opinion was always on
the hunt for scapegoats after the
disastrous battles of the Somme and
Verdun in January of 1917 matter Harry
returned to Paris and demanded to meet
LeDoux to claim her reward but he simply
shunned her errands she was running out
of money and running out of Hope then on
the 19th of February the doozy M bureau
issued an arrest warrant against earth
the charges were espionage on behalf of
Germany matter Harry was taken to so
Lazare Paris's harshest women's prison
she who had once been at home in some of
the most luxurious hotels of Europe now
I had to survive in a flea-ridden and
overcrowded jail for three months she
was interrogated by investigative
magistrate Pierre Bhushan door an
unforgiving man with a prejudiced
against so-called loose women like
matter Henry during this time LeDoux
kept her completely isolated especially
from a lawyer who nay another ex-lover
runs from her fiance
Vladimir Tamar Slav finally on the 24th
of July matter Harry went on trial once
one of the most beautiful women in
Europe she appeared ill bloated and
tired but she was not defeated Rene was
not experienced in military trials but
he did a fair job he pointed out that
the only evidence against her was the
message intercepted at the Eiffel Tower
which may have been doctored by LeDoux
himself he produced a star witness the
Secretary to the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs who testified the matter Harry's
good character and her loyalty matter
Harry gave a great performance but came
into the jury that a courtesan I admit
it a spy never but it was all the show
char from the very start a few weeks
earlier the 20th of April the disastrous
Nivelle offensive had ground to a halt
40,000 French soldiers had died on a
single day the 16th of April as a
consequence 68 divisions at mutiny in
June refusing to continue fighting and
dying for France the general public they
needed a scapegoat for these failures
and what better could that be than a spy
even better a foreign spy even better
a woman of loose morals according to
author Pat Shipman the seven jurors all
believe the unfounded rumor that matter
Harry's spying had caused the death of
50,000 French soldiers how could she
possibly stand a chance against that on
the 27th of July the judge pronounced
the verdict of guilty of espionage and
treason the sentence was death to be
carried out by firing squad on the
morning of the 15th of October Mata Hari
was driven to the Van Sant castle on the
outskirts of Paris six months of
incarceration had taken their toll on a
legendary beauty even so she decided to
wear finest clothes for the occasion the
firing squad officer offered to
blindfold her but she refused
instead she looked defiantly at her
captors and her executors legend says
that she blew a kiss to one of the
soldiers of the firing squad and one to
the priest there to offer her the last
rites
then the squad commander raised his
saber journalists and eyewitness Harry
Wales wrote she did not die how actors
and moving picture stars would have us
believe that people die when they are
shot she don't throw up their hands nor
did she plunge straight forward or
straight back instead she seemed to
collapse slowly in ugly she settled to
her knees her head up always and without
the slightest change of expression on
her face she lay prone motionless with
her face turned towards the sky a
noncommissioned officer drew his
revolver bending over he placed the
revolver almost but not quite against
the left temple of the spy he pulled the
trigger and the bullet tore into the
brain of the woman she had tied Europe's
richest and most powerful men to a
little finger she had Europe's
audience's at her feet but when the
Belle époque ended and the war to end
all wars have broken out Mata Hari
had failed to stay afloat she had been
condemned by her naivety rather than her
cunning and had been framed by Petty and
vengeful men yet she faced her last
weeks on earth with a great dignity
giving her best ever performance on that
cold October morning the sergeant major
supervising the firing squad remarked at
the time by god this lady knows how to
die so thank you for watching today's
video and let us know your veggies in
the
mence do you think matter Harry was a
legendary spy or maybe just a martyr of
a great game that she couldn't control
if you want to know more about World War
one check out our video about Kaiser
Wilhelm right here so as always please
do subscribe and hit the bell icon to
make sure you don't miss out on any of
our videos and I'll see you next time
thank you for watching
[Music]